our next guest a backup at Northern Iowa
for three years before breaking into the
starting lineup and leading the Panthers
to an 84 record started for one season
signed by the Packers where he was
widely considered the fourth best
quarterback on the team he then joined
the Iowa Barnstormers of the Arena
Football League and the Amsterdam
Admirals looks like there's a lot more
stuff here but unfortunately that's all
the time we have for this introduction
please welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
you can see Kurt throughout the NFL
Network's Super Bowl coverage from
Atlanta Super Bowl Sunday cm on a
special eight-hour edition of NFL
gameday morning starting at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern on the NFL Network also a Hall
of Famer
what is tougher like that whole
introduction also Hall of Famers yeah
okay
what's tougher playing in a Super Bowl
or doing an eight and a half hour
pregame show yeah probably eight and a
half hours
sorry trying to keep the energy up for
that long but same kind of thing when
you're preparing for a Super Bowl is you
know you wake up that day and it's so I
mean you've been waiting for the game
for so long but then you have to wait
all day long and I used to hate playing
night games I wanted to wake up go to
the stadium and play football and so
that's that's the hardest part is
managing your emotions because you know
it's the biggest game of your life but
what do you do all day the endings watch
film you know what I did is I would wake
up and eat breakfast and I would try to
go back to sleep
so I would try to treat it like I was
getting up and go into the stadium and
it was a noon game so I would try to
take a nap but you know that sounds
really good but you got the biggest game
of your life and everything's going
through your mind you've been preparing
for this so sometimes I was able to
sleep a little bit sometimes I wasn't
but yeah you're really simply just
trying to manage it and I tried to get
away from football we spent so much time
preparing then I didn't need to look
over it anymore all that did was make
you more nervous more anxious for the
game so I tried to get away from it but
like I said I mean every time you turn
on the TV they're talking about it you
know everybody's texting you talking
about the game so it's nearly impossible
to get away from it but that was what I
tried to do anyways do you remember
anything about the pregame speeches
prior to the Super Bowl
no the only one I remember is my first
Super Bowl right before we we ran out of
the tunnel it was Dick Vermeil myself
Isaac and Marshall and dick just kind of
talking to us about you know that group
and what we meant in the moment that we
had
I don't remember any of the big speeches
don't remember what anybody said at that
point I get so focused yeah that was one
that's one of the things that my my
family always jokes about like like when
I'm I'm texting something to someone I
can't hear anything my kids say you know
my kids will be like dad dad dad and I
get so focused on what I'm doing and I
was the same way with football is that I
just kind of got into my own little
world and I didn't hear anything or
listen to anything I was focused on what
I was doing
it was the same before the game but that
moment was kind of special because you
know of bringing in Marshall at that
time and Isaac kind of being the old
statesman that had been with the team
when they were in LA and then obviously
dick and and myself so it was just a
special moment right as we were getting
ready to run out of the tunnel but I
don't I don't remember anything else at
what point did you realize what Bella
checks game plan was against you guys in
taking Marshall Faulk out of the offense
well it wasn't just Marshall but I think
we realized very early that their
approach was going to be we're gonna
beat these guys out we're gonna grab
them and hold them and be physical with
them because our offense was all about
timing yeah you know all about ball out
before guys are breaking and all of that
stuff so I truly believe they went into
this and said the officials don't like
to call a lot of penalties they don't
think we're doing what Seattle did in
you know in the Legion of bloom they
were manhandling you guys at the line
exactly you're not gonna throw how many
pass interference flags are you gonna
throw especially early in the game yeah
and that's what happened is early in the
game they just threw us off because they
were so physical in the second half they
started to call some of those penalties
things loosened up we were able to get
back into the game and tie it late in
the game but I look back and I go what a
genius approach I mean to go let's force
them to call penalties we know they
don't want to slow this game down and
have a bunch of you know the officials
you know dictating what the game is so
let's do it until they force us not to
do it because it's really who we were
and you know so I tipped my hat to him
with that game plan and then as you said
the other nugget that they had was they
put two linebackers on the edge of the
line of scrimmage and every time
Marshall released
from the backfield in one of their
directions grab him hit him
don't let him get going out of the
backfield and so you know but that was
the beginning of what you came to
realize is Bill Belichick in his ability
to design things you know the ironic
thing we played him earlier that year
you know during the season and during
that game they went with seven DBS and
they were giving us all these crazy
looks and so you prepare for that and we
go into the Super Bowl and we see you
know I mean it was completely different
but that's who Bill Belichick is is you
don't have no idea what they did last
week two weeks ago what they did to you
earlier in the year even if they beat
you doesn't mean they're gonna do the
same thing so you've got to be ready to
adjust to whatever you see on Super Bowl
Sunday did you have any idea that you're
watching a potential hall-of-famer
in Tom Brady at that at that point
absolutely not I mean he did win the
Super Bowl MVP in that game but I
believe you threw for like 150 yards or
less than 150 yards the only thing I'll
say is what Tom Brady has I mean he's
great in so many different ways but what
makes him so special is how good he is
in the moment you know when they need
that one drive and when we see it time
and time again we saw it against Kansas
City a couple weeks ago and if there was
one thing that you can look back and go
maybe that was a little glimpse you know
we tied the game with two minutes to go
and he made a couple big throws a couple
great decision John Madden
famously said you know you're not gonna
try to win it with this with Brady
you're gonna go into overtime and next
thing you know he connects on a couple
of passes finitary kicks and we thought
the same thing
you know because we had taken the
momentum of the game and we thought well
they're not gonna come out here and
throw it because if you know incomplete
passes or whatever happens we get the
ball back we're gonna win this football
game
I mean if you go back and look at that
Super Bowl the very first pass they
threw Leonard little was about two
inches from from knocking the ball away
from Tom Brady and he steps up and
eludes that and drops one off but that
was maybe the one thing that you saw
when you look back and go he's pretty
good in that moment he was pretty good
at making those plays in that two-minute
drive and you look back now I mean eight
berbils everyone has been dictated by
one score in every game that he's played
in has come down to a one-possession
game and obviously he's he's won a bunch
of Ummah and because he's so good in
that moment all the favor Kurt Warner
joining us here in the man cave in
Atlanta if you would give Jared Goff
advice if he would ask for advice what
would you tell him about facing
Belichick well I mean I think the one
thing I would tell him is that you have
to realize this game is like every other
game when you get between the lines you
know there's absent flows of every game
I look back at my three Super Bowls the
first one we were had 16 to nothing it
was tied 16 16 in the fourth quarter
just talked about the one in 2001 we
were down 17 to 3 tied up at 17 to 17
with two minutes to go and then you know
the one against Pittsburgh later we were
down 10 at halftime took the lead with
two and a half minutes to go in the game
so every game even big games like this
with high stakes they have their ebbs
and flows momentum shifts very quickly
and that's what I would tell him is you
got to ride the waves of the Super Bowl
no matter which way it goes you might
jump up early you got to be able to
sustain that you might fall down early
similar to what they did in New Orleans
you've got to ride that wave even though
it's the biggest game of your life even
though you know Tom Brady's on the other
sideline and there's a lot of pressure
in that moment you've got to allow the
game to come to you and the guys that
don't do that are the ones that get
blown out in Super Bowls the guys that
do that are the guys that have a chance
to win late in games and that would be
the one piece of advice I'd give and of
course you had the the great finish here
in Atlanta how nervous with because
quarterbacks want the ball with the game
on the line you had to watch you had to
watch as you know Dyson nearly scores
the touchdown Mike Jones makes the
tackle what's it like on the sidelines
when you have no control yeah it's it's
the worst thing in the world you know
it's the worst thing in the world but I
tell you it's when it works out in your
favor it's one of the best things in the
world because we have the ultimate team
sport is you know basketball yeah it's a
team game but you can play on both ends
of the court you know baseball you can
hit an field you know and so
the hardest thing about footballs you
only get to play one way outside of
obviously those rare exceptions and so
it becomes the ultimate team game is you
have to do your part and then you have
to believe and expect your you know your
teammates to do their part and you know
it's the hardest thing is that I left
all three of my Super Bowls either tied
or with the lead with less than three
minutes to go and I'm one in two in
Super Bowls but to have a defense or
Mike Jones make the tackle and the
defense come up with a stop it
ultimately brings you together to the
point where you go it takes a team to
win Super Bowls I mean Tom Brady would
tell you the same thing is it he could
be nine and out or he could be ain't no
he could be oh and eight because every
game has come down to that one
possession and it takes both sides so as
hard as it was to sit back and watch and
know I've got no hand in this you know
what happens from this point I've got a
sit and watch the beauty of that Super
Bowl was that I knew that worst case
scenario we were gonna be tied you know
they weren't gonna go 4-2 they were if
they did score we would get another
opportunity in overtime but yeah it's
the most helpless feeling but in the end
it's cool because you get to share that
know everybody had a hand in winning
that game if I gave you a mulligan on
the Pittsburgh loss or the New England
lost New England without question one
because we didn't play our best game and
I think the bottom line when you play in
this moment I don't mind somebody in the
Pittsburgh game was just a great game
great players making great plays when
they needed to we did everything you
know with two and a half minutes to go I
always say this for the first time in
the history of our sport people said the
Cardinals are gonna be Super Bowl champs
yeah and so we were in a place where we
played well enough to win that Super
Bowl against New England we didn't play
our best game you know credit New
England they played well that they did
what they headed but we didn't play and
we had 450 yards of offense and scored
17 points that is not the greatest show
on that was not who we were and so that
game I think about more than any other
because you want in your biggest moment
to play your best football and we didn't
on that day and you know there's so many
moments that you know that can change
the outcome of the game I was I had the
the fortune I was handing out the Super
Bowl trophy in the Arizona Pittsburgh
Super Bowl so I'm on the sidelines and
I'm with Steve Young so I'm standing
next to Steve Young as Ben gets the ball
for the two minute drive right Steve
Young is doing play-by-play to me about
what Ben is doing and he is he is so
excited he's just saying this is
unbelievable like he's he's saying you
know what this is what I would do and
then Ben would be doing it and then it's
just playing out in real time because I
thought you guys were gonna win the
Super Bowl
so I'm thinking okay Warner's gonna be
up there Larry Fitzgerald's up there of
a mr. Bidwell like I'm thinking who's up
on the rodeo all of a sudden Ben's here
he escapes here who've here he's over
here
mrs. Santonio Holmes in the endzone on
the play before yes all of a sudden he
connect and Steve Young is going crazy
because a quarterback watching a
quarterback in that moment which we all
did in the backyard and he said you
don't realize how great that was like
I'm in my mind I'm gonna okay I got mr.
Rooney I got you know coach will be up
there I got who's the MVP Holmes will be
up there I got Rothen so I'm not even
going well that was unbelievable in my
mind I'm going I got to get up on the
podium and interview these people in
front of a hundred million people and it
just you know it unfolds like that so
quickly and then I thought Ben was gonna
be the MVP for that drive right there
but then I thought you were gonna be the
MVP or would be Larry right who's gonna
be the MVP and it was just it was crazy
it just but but that to me is what it's
all about is you know I look back on my
career and you know the Super Bowls and
you know again one-one lost two but I
played in three of the greatest Super
Bowls that have ever been played you
know Super Bowls that came down to the
last minute you know you could say to
the last play and that to me is what
it's all that
best teams great players making plays
when they need to make plays and that's
what I reflect on it is that you see I
got to see the start in and yeah at my
expense but I got to see the start of
this Brady Belichick patriots dynasty
that I don't think we're ever gonna see
again you know so maybe it's it's not as
painful now to go we lost to that team
you know that that's been to nine Super
Bowls and then you know Pittsburgh won
like I said it was great plays I mean
that catch by saying tell me Holmes that
throw by Ben Roethlisberger you just
don't see that very often so you just
have to tip your hat and go and that's
what it's all about and we didn't have
the ball last and they made the plays
they needed to so from that perspective
you step back and go man I'm so grateful
that of the games that I got to play in
on this stage I can feel some
frustration still there would you like
to take out some frustration I got
McLovin McLovin do you want to catch
some passes from Kurt Warner well which
car where am I getting rammed
Kurt Warner Giants corner 47 year old
because of his giant record I'm not it's
a giant skirt well maybe if it's a
Giants one he could throw the first
couple of them I think he lies in the
green room you could come in you got a
little sauce left in that arm I might
have a little left okay all right we'll
take a break McLovin do you have your
receiver gloves
it gets gloves that's like you had a
glove that's true but I don't have it
today I can get you one if you need one
it's just like cheating with those
things it is that's performance enhanced
oh my gosh without a diet without a
doubt it's I mean you see these guys I
mean they're catching it with two
fingers now I know I mean it's ridicu to
40 touchdowns a year two guys wearing
gloves
yeah I'm just complaining cuz you're
wearing
Kurt Warner NFL Network analyst
hall-of-famer Super Bowl MVP and you can
see him eight and a half hour edition of
NFL gameday morning I think it starts
when you leave here that's because these
guys want it if he's got one eight and a
half hours I wouldn't have to get up so
we're 9:00 a.m. Eastern on the NFL
Network we'll come back if you're
watching you can see Kurt Warner's smoke
McLovin right after this
all right so McLovin takes on usually
quarterbacks who are playing now yeah so
since you've retired you know this
shouldn't be that big of a deal surf now
you know you should move now you can
throw it that fall I mean I can throw it
that okay I just won man yeah this is
like it's like an arena stadium right
here it kind of Pryor the Arena League
Barnstormer okay so bounce off the wall
you know why don't you just give it just
a little like moderate heat there to
make moderate Heat yeah let's just see
what we got - why the movie uh so that's
just moderate speed now you can just amp
it up a little bit your move before the
ball even gets there you gotta know
you've got your gloves and your helmet
on and you yeah would it be can you
throw to me as I hike Ross behind that
truck you're the one that was making fun
of me but is that it how we're going
alright wait wait what do you mean that
one to go in the last one
now we're going okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
at least try to catch it I mean it's a
goal just to get out of the way and I
kept trying to catch it here how would
that play in the heart he did that by
giving one more one more
Fitzgerald never did that did he no you
never liked more now I'm not afraid for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]